Oprah Winfrey sets the record straight  on rumors that she will run for  president  [Music]  will you please run for president one  day that will never happen to me  I think we have you know we America has  spoken that will net that is the one  thing I can say will never happen to me  that's what Oprah told et back in  November but a lot of people still seem  to think she'll step into the Oval  Office one day so just to be clear  here's Lady OH repeating herself on the  Hollywood Reporter's Awards chatter  podcast this week I will never run for  public office that's a pretty definitive  thing when asked if she thought she  could beat President Donald Trump if he  sought a second term the legendary talk  show host reiterated quote I will never  have to know the answer to that because  I will never run for public office  everybody can take a deep breath now  [Music]